who is skinny lazy any razor this fella
from Philadelphia was a was a made
member of the Philadelphia mob whose
captain actually and he took my uncle
under his wing when my uncle was young
around 16 17 years old and my uncle
would hang with him alive
and he introduced my uncle to all the
guys in New York all the bosses and
everybody he knew he knew a lot of
people and that's how my uncle got to
know everybody over there and that's how
they got to know my uncle on his
reputation it was he a historian was a
guy that knew the history of the mob or
know skini was yes yes skinny was my
talk my uncle and my uncle knew all the
laws of the Cosa Nostra do too skinny do
too skinny
also skinny was a stone killer he killed
a lot of guys and that's how my uncle
got Bob well what killing people with
them so skinny skinny was known for
being a killer when you say in a lot of
guys what's what's the number with
somebody like him was he I had no idea
dozens or Z is it is it God I would say
at least a dozen I mean okay would kill
people he would he got the OK to kill
this fellow with my uncle that lived in
South Philadelphia now this fella was
like in a former for the police one day
during a snowstorm he grabbed my uncle
said come on let's go they walked in the
snowstorm because nobody was out driving
or anything they went in the store and
they killed this guy who was the
informer and they cut his balls off and
they stuck it in his mouth and that's
the type of guy my uncle was and skinny
razor did you ever get a chance to meet
skinny no he died I never met him
you never met up now but everybody know
who he was got a reputation yes what did
he die a vicious way or was it just a he
had a heart attack I believe what a way
to coming into mob world that's a good
way to go yeah
[Music]